well as it stands right now next Monday
this coming Monday Brett Kavanaugh and
his accuser Christine Ford will both
appear before a Senate committee to talk
about the allegations that Ford has has
leveled against Cavanaugh I was reading
manin the the CNN article I don't know
why I was doing that but I was reading
to CNN Arkell if you're wondering if
you're wondering whether or not CNN
might be biased if you're if you're
wondering about that here's the here's
the article on cnn.com about the hearing
that's scheduled for Monday this is what
it says it will be a public reckoning of
a woman's courage a man's character and
the capacity of Washington's leaders to
show that some things matter more than
politics that's the lead paragraph on
this news on this alleged news website
yeah I mean the news media that gets so
offended they they get so personally
offended when Trump constantly calls
them fake news but this is why they're
not even trying to disguise it making no
attempt whatsoever to disguise that they
are all in on Christine Ford's side and
that's their making no attempt to
disguise it the article goes on an
extraordinary American moment is
scheduled to unfold next Monday when the
accused when the accused Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh and his accuser
California professor Christine Blasi
Ford are due to appear before a Senate
committee if it goes ahead as planned
the hearing will become a human drama
that will be agonizing for Ford as she
reveals the most intimate painful
details of an alleged assault it will be
grueling for Cavanaugh as he defends his
reputation over an incident he is
adamant never took place so um yeah if
you're worried about them if you're if
you were curious but maybe you know if
there's maybe a little bit of a bias
problem in the media then there you go
so what make a few more points about all
this
first of all you know one of the most
fallacious arguments that I've heard in
regards to to the to the Brett Kavanaugh
sex abuse allegation it's getting even
call it an argument but I've heard this
online and people have said this to me
over and over again they've said you
know what if it was your daughter who
said that a boy attempted to rape her
what if it was you what if it was your
daughter how would you how would you
respond
and I guess people are saying this to me
because my position has been that I find
these allegations to be extremely
suspicious and dubious and and
unsubstantiated and uncorroborated and
so I think Brett Kavanaugh should still
be confirmed and he should be confirmed
it should be confirmed quickly so people
have said to me in responsib well what
if it was your if it was your daughter
you wouldn't feel that way would you and
you hear this stuff all the time people
try to frame conversations like this all
the time right
they ask you to imagine how you'd
respond if your children were somehow
personally impacted by the issue in
question but but first of all that's
actually exactly the wrong way to think
about situations like this that that is
the wrong mindset to have
our our objective should be to figure
out the truth that's what we should be
trying to figure out what actually
happened what is true and that requires
cool heads and objectivity
it doesn't require strong blinding
emotion which is the which is the
mindset that they well imagine if it was
your child people want us to adopt but
that's wrong because yeah if it was my
day if my daughter told me this story
and she told me right away not 35 years
later um then yeah I would go to the
boy's house and I would beat the crap
out of them that's what I would do but
that's because as a father my anger and
my emotions and my protective instinct
would take over and they would
completely override any rational part of
my brain so I would not I mean I would
that's how I would respond I would
respond in an emotional angry vengeful
violent way
um I would respond probably in an
irrational way but irrationality is not
the answer here
so every time every time we do this
where we say well Matt imagine if you
were affected by this I'm imagine if you
were personally involved no that's
that's the opposite of what you should
do the fact that were removed from the
situation
that's that allows us to to to to be
objective
theoretically but here's something else
to consider you know this is what I've
been thinking about if we're going to
play the hole well what if it was your
child game
why don't we ever consider it from the
other angle
like
okay yo what if it was your daughter
alright but what if it was your son what
if your son was on the cusp of some huge
achievement and a woman came forward
with no evidence and no witnesses and
and and nothing else and accused him of
attempting to assault her years ago but
she doesn't know exactly when or where
what if I had what happened to your son
would you assume that he's a rapist and
throw him to the wolf wolves or would
you demand that he be treated as as
innocent until proven guilty I mean how
would you approach it then why are we
only supposed to imagine ourselves in
the position of the woman or you know
related to the woman somehow what about
the man who is who is supposed to be
innocent until proven guilty and also in
fact let let me say this that because
this comparison doesn't really work
because the willya what if it was your
daughter that whole thing obviously in
that situation were meant to imagine
ourselves being told this by our
daughter right after it happened
but
if I was if I were Christine Ford's dad
you know right now who must be in his
70s or 80s or whatever and if my
daughter told me that she planned to
publicly accuse a prominent figure of a
sexual assault that supposedly happened
35 years ago and that she never before
mentioned to me or anyone else and that
she has no evidence to prove and no
witnesses to corroborate and she doesn't
even remember all the details like when
it Wynn and where it happened in that
case you know what I think I'd probably
advise her against it I think in that
case uh well it's hard for me to know
exactly what I would say to my daughter
like cuz I can't even imagine having a
daughter who's who's in her 50s but I
think there's a very good chance that I
would advise her no I would not I would
not go forward with it with allegations
like this in this situation now there
are no you know there's no statute of
limitations for accusations of course so
you can accuse anyone of anything any
time but there's a reason why they have
a statute of limitations in a court of
law because if you wait too long and
then you make your app's accusation
there's absolutely no way to prove or
disprove anything you're saying
so the accusation can damage the person
that you've accused but he's not going
to have the opportunity to vindicate
himself
so I think I think it's reasonable to
expect someone if they're gonna come
forward with an accusation to do it
I don't know within what like a decade
two decades I mean some time before the
middle of the third decade I think
that's reasonable
I think if thirty five years have passed
and you haven't said anything by now
that I think it's reasonable to say well
you know it's it's kind of too late it's
too late to come forward with this you
you had you had thirty five years to do
it and you didn't so to do it now you
can't accomplish anything except accept
cause much of chaos hurt this guy's
reputation but that's all it can do you
you can't prove anything to come out
publicly against somebody thirty-five
years later with a vague memory I mean I
think it in most cases it's not right to
do that and notice how she remembers all
these details except the two that would
allow him to vindicate himself and prove
his innocence
okay so she remembers all this stuff she
doesn't remember exactly where or win
though that seems kind of convenient to
me because those are the two details
that could potentially allow him to
prove he that he was innocent because he
could say oh well I was that you know I
was I was I was overseas in France I
mean we've I was all booth on vacation
with my parents and in Canada on that
day or you know he could I mean
potentially he could may be proven or
you could or or on the other hand if you
had an exact day and and location then
that would allow you to find some
evidence to prove his guilt
but when somebody said when it's when
it's even if it's not threatening think
even even if it's like 10 years like 5
years later a year later and somebody
says well sometime within a span of like
you know sometime within this large span
of time in some location in the general
vicinity of this county you know this
person did this thing well there's just
no way there's no way for someone if
someone said about you
that
between ten and fifteen years ago in
this general vicinity of this of this
particular County you did a horrible
thing there will be absolutely no way
for you to prove your innocence you
could not do it
because it's just it's it's it's it's
too broad of a timeframe
so it's just it's not it's just not
right I don't think it's right
you
I mean at the very least if you're gonna
come out 35 years later you should have
every last detail down starting with
when and where if you don't even have
that
iii-it's if you don't even have that
that I don't I don't know how you come
forward now I think
you know I liberals are saying that and
if you go you know if you if you if you
go online or go on Twitter there's the
phrase that you're gonna see repeated
over and over again is credibly accused
right there saying that Kavanagh has
been credibly accused which is just the
real which is just a which is just
another way of them saying that he's
guilty you know when you say incredibly
accused it's it's just another way of
accused of straight up saying the guys
killed credibly accused so it's a
euphemism for guilty but we're told that
this is a credible act this is a
credible accusation accusation it's 35
years old don't know exactly when don't
know exactly where both the other
witnesses have denied it that's a
credible accusation supposedly I don't
know if I would call that a credible
accusation but then you could say well
if that's not a credible accusation what
is I'm I'm glad that you asked just that
just by way this is not a what about
thing is not what about ISM but just
because we're thrown around terms like
credible accusation I think it could be
helpful to to look at what an actual
credible accusation looks like so for
that
I go to Juanita Broderick
who accused Bill Clinton as I think well
everyone knows now accused Bill Clinton
of violently raping her this was not an
attempted rape
this was violent actual rape that Bill
Clinton is alleged to have alleged to
have done to - Juanita Broderick now let
me this is actually um funny enough this
is from BuzzFeed ok BuzzFeed it or not
did a actually did a very thorough
article a couple years ago about this
accusation so let me read just their
description of of what happened of the
accusation itself from Juanita Broderick
okay
Broderick this is the accusation
Broderick then 35 first melp met Bill
Clinton when he was 31 and the Attorney
General of Arkansas during a campaign
stop he made at her nursing home where
she worked
they discussed her business and his
campaign Broderick wasn't much into
politics but she had recently started
volunteering for him with a friend and
Clinton told Broderick to call his
office if she was ever ever in nearby
Little Rock a few week a few weeks later
she did just that while attending a
nursing seminar there they arranged to
meet one morning in the coffee shop in
the hotel where the seminar was held at
the last second Clinton called up to
Broderick's room and asked if they could
meet there instead since there were
reporters in the lobby below she said
yes
minutes after entering her room he tried
to kiss her she says biting her upper
lip hard shocked
Broderick says she resisted Clinton even
telling her she was not only married but
having an affair with another man who
would later become her second husband he
ignored her she says and pushed around
the bed and raped her afterwards she
says he put his sunglasses on and told
her to get some ice for her swollen lip
before leaving the room there was no
remorse Broderick told me he acted like
it was an everyday occurrence he was not
the least bit apologetic it was just
unreal she rushed to the door and locked
that she says Freight afraid that
someone would come back to kill her
two of Broderick's friends who had also
attended the nursing conference found
Broderick in tears her lips swollen and
blue she told them what had happened but
made them swear not to tell anyone else
she was scared of retaliation didn't
think anyone would believe her and
blamed herself for allowing Quentin to
come up into her room
I never told I had never known anyone
that had been raped she told me I could
not imagine anybody that could get in
that situation and not get out of it
soon after Broderick says she ran into
Hillary Clinton at a political rally and
Hillary shook her hand and thanked her
for everything she had done for Bill the
Broderick the gesture felt like a threat
to stay silent as Attorney General later
Governor Bill Clinton was quote the main
person that regulated my business and my
income Broderick said after she said
after she said what she did to me I just
thought I will keep quiet okay so what
makes that credible while the accusation
against Cavanaugh is not as credible
blow that quite a few things number one
she remembers exactly where and when it
happened she remembers all the details
she remembers how she ended up there she
remembers everything
um number two
she told two people about it moments
after it happened and not only that
those people found her bruised and
bloodied
so those are two really important
aspects of this whole thing number three
she has a reason she has a she has a
rational reason now she didn't she
didn't come foot public with these
accusations I don't think for another
until like 98 99 so for her it was about
20 years before she came before she came
out publicly with these accusations but
if she didn't wait 20 years to tell
anybody she didn't even want me she went
she waited hardly even 20 minutes to
tell anybody she did tell her friends um
but it makes sense why she would have
waited 20 years she and she said it
right there first of all she thought
that she felt like Bill Clinton's wife
was threatening her second Bill Clinton
exercised a lot of control over her
personally given what she did for living
and his position third he was a very
powerful man as Attorney General he
became even more powerful as as governor
and then he became even more powerful as
president so she was she was worried
about about the power that he had and
about his his uh be what she felt was a
was an underhanded threat from his wife
so we have that so we have exact day and
time and location we have she reported
it to to two other people at right after
it happened she has a reach his actual
reason she'd give why she didn't tell
anybody and and then the fourth thing
was his alt which is also really
important that this fits a pattern of
behavior there are several other women
who have who came out and accused Bill
Clinton as well and so we have an
established pattern of behavior where
it's pretty much an accepted fact that
Bill Clinton is is a is a sexual
deviants come back so with all of those
things taken into consideration the the
evidence is overwhelming that there's
really there's there's actually no
reason to disbelieve Juanita Broderick
there is no rational reasonable
justification for disbelieving her it is
over what evidence is overwhelmingly in
her favor
so that unless you are a total partisan
hack you would you would believe Juanita
Broderick
because in one EDA Broderick's case it's
it's her word along with all the other
women that accused Bill Clinton against
Bill Clinton who he knows a pathol
pathological liar and sexual deviant so
it's just I mean there's no again
there's no reason not to believe
it's entirely a different case with
Christine Ford and judge Cavanaugh
doesn't remember remember doesn't
remember exactly when doesn't remember
exactly where there was alcohol you know
she admits herself to I believe that she
was drinking as well there was alcohol
involved
they were both kids it was 35 years ago
she didn't tell anyone for at least 30
years no other women have come forward
there's as far as we know there is no
established pattern of behavior here no
other women have come forward to accuse
him so it is entirely her word against
his and he's also got plenty of other
women who knew him at the time and have
vouched for his character so it's just
in his case I think the the evidence is
much more in his favor
and so that's the difference that's a
credible accusation verse a not so
credible accusation so if you are among
the many liberals who have found
Christine Ford's accusations very
credible
yet somehow Juanita Broderick's
accusations not credible then you really
need to look in your heart and in your
mind
to figure out what's going on with you
because there's something going
seriously wrong with you in that case
you have been totally blinded by your
partisan affiliations
which is which is shameful all right
I'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks listening Godspeed